SENATE CANDIDATE IN THIS IN A
REPUBLICAN, BLAKE MASTERS FOR
HIS ASSESSMENT OF WHAT IS GOING
ON.
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH GARY
LAKE, IT'S HARD TO KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
WHAT IS YOUR BEST ASSESSMENT?
>> I GUESS, WE'VE GOT MESSED UP
ELECTIONS FOR STARTERS FOR THEY
COUNTED A LOT OF BALLOTS, BUT
THEY'RE STILL ABOUT HALF ENOUGH
MILLION LEFT TO BE COUNTED.
THESE ARE HARD-CORE REPUBLICAN
BORDER VOTERS.
THEY BROUGHT THEIR ELECTION IN
ON.
WE ARE STARTING TO GET A FEW OF
TODAY'S NUMBERS TRICKLING IN.
WE ARE GETTING FROM SOME OF
THESE DROPPED DROP 74 PERCENT O
THE VOTE.
THESE ARE HEAVY DUTY REPUBLICAN
VOTERS.
ISN'T IT CONVENIENT THAT THEY
ARE THE LAST BALLOTS TO BE THEY
COUNT ALL OF THE DEMOCRAT AND
THE ROOT RELIABLE REPUBLICAN
BALLOTS ARE THE LAST TO BE
COUNTED SO WE ARE LESS THAN A
POINT AWAY FROM OUR OPPONENTS,
AND WE THINK IT'S GOING TO STAR
TURNING AND TURNING QUICKLY.
WE BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO WIN
WITH A NICE PADDING ACTUALLY.
>> SO YOUR OPPONENT IS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE,.
SHE DIDN'T CAMPAIGN MUCH AND SH
DIDN'T SEEM LIKE SHEET NEEDED T
CAMPAIGN A LOT, SHE NEVER
DEBATED YOU AND SOME ARE
SPARKING ONLINE WILL OF COURSE,
SHE WAS ALWAYS CONFIDENT IN HER
VICTORY.
WHAT IS THAT YOUR TAKE ON THAT
PART OF THE RACE?
>> YOU ARE TRYING TO GET ME TO
SAY SOMETHING THAT MIGHT GET ME
IN TROUBLE.
>> NO, I READ 50 PEOPLE SAY THAT
.
THAT MEANS PEOPLE ARE SO
DISTRUSTFUL, WHAT THEY ARE
INSINUATING IS SHE KNEW SHE
COULD SIT BACK, HIDE IN THE
BASEMENT, DO NOTHING AND WIN DU
TO CHEATING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE INSINUATING.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WOULD
INSINUATE THAT BECAUSE WE'VE HA
SUCH TERRIBLE ELECTIONS.
THEY ARE RUN POORLY, THEY ARE
RIFE WITH FRAUD.
WE'VE SEEN THIS TIME AND AGAIN.
NOTHING IS BEING DONE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS TELL US IF WE
DARE BRING IT UP, WE ARE
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, WE ARE
ELECTION DENIERS, WE HAVE TO
START BRINGING THIS UP, I WAS I
A VETERANS DAY PARADE TODAY AND
PEOPLE WERE SHOUTING OUT ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD, PLEASE REPAIR
OUR ELECTIONS.
PLEASE COUNT OUR VOTE.
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA ARE FED UP
.
WHEN WE WIN, AND REST ASSURED W
WILL, WITH 100 PERCENT CERTAINT
WE WILL.
ONE OF THE FIRST EXAM GOING TO
DO IS CALL A SPECIAL SESSION,
BRING THE LEGISLATURE IN AND SA
FIX THESE ELECTIONS AND RESTORE
HONESTY AND TRANSPARENCY SO WE
CAN HAVE FAITH IN OUR ELECTIONS
ONCE AGAIN.
THIS IS OUR SACRED VOTE.
WE WANT TO KNOW THAT VOTE
COUNTED.
AGAIN AND NOT ACCUSING YOUR
OPPONENT OF DOING ANYTHING WRONG
.
BUT SHE IS THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND IT SEEMS THAT ONE OF
THE MAIN COST OF AN ELECTION
THIS CHAOTIC IS THE CONFIDENCE
OF VOTERS THAT IT'S REAL.
WHY WOULDN'T SHE RECUSE YOURSEL
FOR APPEARANCE SAKE IF NO OTHER
BEFORE THE COUNT BEGAN?
>> WE ASKED HER TO DO THAT ONE
MONTH INTO JUMPING INTO THE RAC
BACK IN JULY OF 2021, WE ASKED
HER TO RECUSE HERSELF WE SAID
THIS IS UNETHICAL JUST RECUSE
YOURSELF FROM THE PARTS OF YOUR
ROLE AS SECRETARY OF STATE THAT
DEAL WITH THE ELECTION AND SHE
REFUSED TO DO SO.
SHE ONLY SHOWED UP FOR WORK 19
DAYS AND THE PAST SIX MONTHS, S
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH WORK SHE
DOES.
WE HAD THE BIG RED FLAG ON
AUGUST 2ND, THE PRIMARY ELECTIO
THAT PLAYED OUT EXACTLY LIKE
THIS.
THEY COUNTED THE DEMOCRAT VOTES
FIRST BASE WILL ROLLED THE
REPUBLICAN VOTES, AND IT WAS
DAYS AND DAYS AND DAYS OF
COUNTING.
THEY DID NOTHING TO IMPROVE IT
BEFORE THIS GENERAL ELECTION AN
THAT WE HAVE THE TABULATOR
MACHINES THAT DIDN'T WORK AND
ONE THIRD OF THE POLLING PLACES.
WE CAN'T RUN ELECTIONS THIS WAY.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THESE ELECTION
ARE THESE COUNTS ARE GOING TO
START GOING HEAVILY OUR WAY AND
WE WILL WIN THIS.
I SURE THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA
THAT WE WILL CLEAN UP OUR
ELECTIONS.
>> I WOULD ELIMINATE ABSENTEE
BALLOTS AND EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT REALLY NEED TH